pour mériter le désert il faut
s'éloigner un peu de la vie et cette
balade en voiture n'est qu'un avant goût
de ce qui les attend
ces touristes emportent avec eux leur
sac à dos mais aussi de quoi tenir deux
semaines
loin de tout
nous sommes dans le sud algérien une
destination hors des sentiers battus
on a qui m'ont dit tu es drôle d'idée
notamment des algériens qui sont des
gens d'origine algérienne qui
travaillent avec moi mais finalement
comme il s'est jamais rien passé dans le
sud de l'algérie même depuis les
événements ma foi on est venu
ils sont venus et maintenant ils vont
voir 10 heures de marche par jour
la nuit à la belle étoile à mais des
températures parfois proche de zéro
le dépaysement est garanti
une caravane de chameaux accompagne les
marcheurs avec tout ce qu'il faut pour
le bivouac en chapelier un guide et un
cuisinier au total cinq personnes sont
là pour veiller au bien-être des
voyageurs venus partager le mode de vie
des touareg
une aventure qui nécessite un peu
d'endurance
il faut savoir marcher mettre un pied
devant l'autre et puis ne pas trop être
attaché à son confort j'irai mais c'est
pas c'est pas très difficile d'abord ça
permet d'éviter est fait noël les scènes
de réveillant cetera
d'une part et pluie n'ont cessé c'est
bon c'est agréable de se retrouver ou en
terre de vivre au rythme du soleil de la
nature en fait on retrouve des gestes un
peu primitif quoi donc ça c'est la
première premières impressions après les
recherches
les connections d'un monde qui parfois
un peu
trop matérialiste donc du coup forcément
on revient dès ses propres créations
au menu de ce midi salade verte et
fromages le repas chaud c'est pour ce
soir
seul ombre à ce tableau idyllique
c'est que l'afflux des touristes
viennent briser le fragile équilibre du
sart on ne jette rien aux rouges et à
rien on apprend au mollet sagna qui
n'étaient pas déjà quand on part d'un
cadavre comme il était
foulée un désir intact retrouvez le
silence et la solitude des grands
espaces
c'est ce qui attire ces marcheurs
parti tout simplement
à la rencontre de même